So suppose that we have a smarter tester, a tester which can detect when any
state is identical to a previously visited state. In that case the tester may
decide that this, this, and this state are identical to the initial state and
therefore dismiss them. The tester also dismisses this state, as usual,
because of the problem specification that one cannot have more prisoners than
guards on any one bank. This leaves the following state of affairs.
Note also that this particular state has no successor states,
all successor states of this have been ruled out. Therefore this particular part
clearly is not a good path to get to the gold state. If we notice also,
that these two states are identical, then we can merge them. If we do so,
then we get exactly the same kind of configuration of states that we had when we
were dealing with the semantic network in the previous lesson. There is
something to note here. We had this semantic network in the last lesson, but
the knowledge representation of semantics network, while very useful,
by itself and of itself doesn't solve any problems.
You need a problem solving method that uses knowledge afforded by the knowledge
representation to actually do the problem solving. Generating test is one
of those problem solving methods. In general, when we do problem solving or
reasoning, then there is a coupling between a knowledge representation and
a problem solving method, like semantic networks and generating test.
What we did so far had a dumb generator, but we made the testers smarter.
The testers started looking for what states had been repeated.
Alternatively we can shift the balance of responsibility between them and
make the generator smarter. Let's see how that might happen.